[Music]
the flash is just aired its 100th
episode and as always the show is packin
some big twists and reveals that
definitely deserve discussion throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the season 5 milestone episode as well
as what it means for the future there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want to have the big twist ruined
and I highly suggest that you turn off
now but everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to even though we've told Barry
time and time again to stop messing with
the timeline episode 100 follows him and
Nora travelling to key events in the
show's history one of these revisits was
to the time season 2 Barry spoke with
season 1 eobard thawne but those who are
scratching their head already this was
when the titular character traveled back
for help from his arch-nemesis during
this encounter thorn senses Nora and
guesses that it is his daughter whilst
reminiscing and dropping names of the
other versions that had died it's here
that we discover that Nora and II ibadah
actually in collusion with each other
and have been working together for the
entire season whilst this might
immediately point her out as a villain
executive producer Todd he'll being
recently revealed that she's working
with him because in the future her
mother isn't telling her any information
so she goes to him for very specific
info which then leads to them building a
relationship that will start to impact
with the second half of the season
Jessica Parker Kennedy who plays Nora
also stay at that I'm really interested
to see if fans enjoy it or if they hate
it and how they feel about Nora if
they're going to like her or not like
her to me this points out that Nora is
still one of the good guys and is trying
to do the right thing but just going
about it the wrong way
Nora is still quite young and naive and
she could have easily been swayed by
master manipulator
eobard thawne much in the same way that
he controlled Barry throughout season 1
obviously I'm really interested in
hearing your thoughts on the season as
well as where you think the storyline
will go make sure you leave your
theories on the show below and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my review of this week's
big
trailer Captain Marvel this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]